welcome to this video I am the governor
I am okay what do we get Scott Shaw
nights no this one spanish four nights
what that have never seen in my life why
is that even possible okay hmm
okay let's just draw back the main point
of an opening like that is to irritate
the opponent and maybe em yeah try for
check tricks with no time on the clock
now here white is slightly better but
usually i spent like a minute and then i
have a good position or horror or more
and then lose on time against those we
had sidelines
yeah probably will get some trades now
why could um just retreat the night this
ok so I'm going to play for
simplifications here I've got less space
so this is generally welcome to even the
widest of the hospital more space and
two bishops
I wonder if I can go t5 ever if you move
the Queen maybe now maybe you can also
trade just trade that player should be
three also good enough for slide pool
going there okay t5 sf4 just do this
cheer not great at least he doesn't have
a night anymore that you can plant on d5
but um what is of course a lot more
comfortable here so how to do this maybe
here F 494
just yeah Knight to d7 I guess
after the Queen trade I think I'm okay
if he trades on g6 I can think about
trading on g3 it's it's it's passive but
it's still difficult to break a bit
surprised how we set this up and you
form so it's probably okay am I seem
Argo g5 yep let's do that
okay now is going back mm I wonder if
four is a move on yeah I think I can do
that I mean see voice somewhat somewhat
tender so Noel taking now doesn't make
much sense I wonder fc5 as some kind of
move or if d 6 is 2 2 week yeah i'm
going to try to double behind the a poem
I think this is okay actually because
it's very difficult for him to me to get
in a form with recapturing with a pawn I
think it's almost impossible to do
can I do something night coming to
deform I can try Knight a5 b5 takes
Bishop b3 is that it's that too
ambitious again I can't help myself so
here I can take on b 31 c 4 then i'll be
3k probably not going to work so i have
to do this
yeah I'm really comfortable I am I think
least I don't see anything threatening
so mm can I put the night on e six maybe
try to provoke him to push that forward
not you five maybe okay it's not
necessarily a problem okay then f5
came that I should have just stayed
maybe got a bit too ambitious them
could have just stayed and nothing ever
happens hmm Kim
check
draw our third time morning I'm not
really sure what this is can I do
something here on this on the points
there g2 and Bishop see two widows ideas
if you move this 95 when I d3
no probably is a draw
yeah I think it's a true draw offered
draw offered drawn I've drawn think it
really is one I don't I don't say I
cannot really win him I think I'm not
quite sure maybe maybe I could have done
something around here think he was
ambitious of course but i'm not sure if
it was was really good like here maybe
hear something else if I've was mm-hmm
was it was it was important i saw a bit
too late can I do this maybe
yeah I'm okay but I cannot really do
much in terms of playing or an advantage
I think this end game was okay for me
despite white having the bishop pair it
is just very very blocked and he has
problems with getting something going g3
f4 would be good under the right
circumstances but I don't really see how
it happens and if he plays before to do
something on the queenside c4 gets
weekend yeah i think it's it's probably
a draw oh it's equal and it's same this
was still interesting he could have
taken on b5 may be here fortunately i
didn't have any anything else couldn't
sacrifice a piece or something yeah
probably a fair result the draw okay
thanks for watching